this is the jocko dmz podcast episode
one
sitting here with echo charles so i get
a random
text
from you echo charles get a random text
from echo
and it says the whole world thinks
you're on steroids
which i did there's no context around it
and i wrote back
why is that or something along those
lines
and then you sent me the link to this
youtube video um of more plates more
dates which is the youtube channel
and it's this video
and they're trying to
decipher
whether i'm on steroids
or on
trt
so
uh i laughed it was funny it was funny
and the like the subtitle of it is he
trains three times a day sleeps five
hours and is [ __ ] huge that's the
that's the title of it
and it's funny uh it's
so i laughed smile a little bit and it's
it's kind of funny for me to people
to think i'm on steroids or on um
testosterone um
it's a good compliment because i'm not
and uh i don't have anything i i don't
have anything against people that do
steroids unless you're like uh competing
in
a sport where you're not supposed to you
do that kind of stuff
and then i don't really yeah then you
shouldn't do it but i know a lot of
people
that are on
either are on steroids have been on
steroids i know a lot of people that
have been on trt which interestingly the
fact what i'm saying right now is one of
the things that this guy his name is
derek and i've watched a bunch of his
videos before yeah um randomly uh he's a
well-educated guy he's a smart guy he's
pretty funny too yeah
but
he that's one of the things that he sort
of mentioned when he makes his
conclusion
which
the the conclusion of the video is and i
forgot i've got the exact quote written
down here somewhere it was kind of like
yeah he's probably done steroids and
he's
almost definitely on trt which was his
conclusion which was interesting because
the guy does have a lot of knowledge
about this kind of stuff
but it's weird because even as he was
saying coming to this conclusion
you got a lot of he kept backpedaling a
little bit but then kind of moving
forward backpedaling moving forward now
here's the deal
um i don't really care what it's i think
it's kind of funny and whatever there's
you're always gonna have stuff said
about you on the internet but here's
where i was a little bit concerned
is if you're a person that's
let's say you're a 18 year old kid and
you think jocko is cool
and you hear this thing then maybe
people are starting to think oh well you
know jocko uses steroids just watch this
video or if you're a person that's in
the military or in law enforcement where
you're putting your job in jeopardy to
use steroids or use
these kind of drugs
then that's bad
and i didn't want to have that out there
where people are like well you know
jocko uses them right
because that's the the conclusion so
um
yeah i wanted to like go through it a
little bit and see how we ended up in
this situation where
where we're at
that's a good point there where i didn't
really think about it in that depth
where
yeah
who cares especially nowadays breath
take take whatever you like unless
you're literally cheating on something
something official whatever but do your
thing
um
but yeah so if
if you're doing it and everyone else is
doing it and it's so like normal in life
or whatever yeah who's the what's to
that'll influence younger people less
knowledgeable people to be like oh
everyone does it even jocko this pillar
of integrity you know in their mind and
all this stuff and so that's how normal
it is and you know it's some influence
it's like false influence you know yeah
so that made me feel like oh maybe we
should we should talk about a little bit
um because that's not cool
uh
the
so how that
let me just give my background a little
bit just kind of so people understand
um
so when i was a kid i was a hardcore kid
i was a straight edge kid if you don't
know what that means that means i didn't
drink i didn't smoke i didn't smoke pot
i didn't do anything like that i was
into hardcore music
and i was what's called straight edge
back in the day so so that's that's the
beginning now if i was into
other kind if i was into uh uh
metal which i was into metal but i moved
past the metal very quickly and into
hardcore and got into that scene
and
so i was in that scene my friends were
in that scene there we are and guess
what when you're in that scene you're
not drinking you're not doing drugs so
there's my high school years yeah
you know like they're done
then what do i do well then i joined the
military
so when you join the military guess what
you can't do drugs
now i drank when i was in the military i
drank a lot probably drank too much
but
if you get caught doing drugs in the
military you get kicked out of the
military even steroids even steroids
even steroids um
now again when look people want to do
drugs i got all kinds of friends that do
drugs
i got all kinds of friends that do drugs
i got friends that smoke pot all day
long
um i got friends that drink a lot i got
friends that do mushrooms and acid and
all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and i don't i i'm these are my
legitimate friends
but i don't do that stuff so i don't
hold anything against them and i got a
lot of friends that have used steroids
for sure and use steroids
for sure people that i train with
sometimes
people that are on trt i know all these
kinds of people i don't i don't i don't
hold one single grudge against them when
someone beats the [ __ ] out of me on the
mats
a roughs me up and i think well you know
oh that guy is probably on stairs or is
on steroids which by the way they
they'll tell me yeah yeah i was uh you
know i'm going to cycle oh cool you know
i don't have any
animosity towards that person
but
in the navy
in the military you can't do that and
there was a bunch of comments
in these sections that were about
everyone in the militaries on stairs
which was crazy for me to read it was
crazy for me to read
um
but okay so i'm in the military if you
use drugs if you use steroids you can
get kicked out there was no way i was
ever gonna sacrifice or put at risk my
military career doing the job i loved
because i wanted to be a little bit
bigger and by the way
i was pretty big
you know like i wasn't
i was good to go i wasn't in this
situation where i was like oh no i hope
i can you know be a little bit stronger
i wasn't in that situation i wasn't in a
situation where i was like oh i hope i
can be a little bit more jacked
i was as jacked as i thought i could
needed to be to do my job do you know
anyone that got in trouble i don't know
kicked out whatever for steroids i know
i know guys that got in trouble
i don't know if anyone got kicked out
um
it i know that it was quote hard to test
for they'd say right they'd be like it's
really hard to test
um so what they would do is they would
take this is a legend right this is this
is what i'd hear and this is the kind of
stuff that i just need to hear this one
time and i'd be like okay cool what they
do is it's really expensive to test for
steroids
so they would test
a hundred
they'd mix them all together and test
for steroids and if it was in there then
they'd do an individual test for each
one of them to save money so i hear that
i'm like okay so they're testing i'm not
gonna do this yet
um and and by the way like
of all my close friends in the seal
teams
there's not one of them
i'm trying to think
i i can't even think of any of them
that was like doing steroids i knew a
guy i knew guys that were peripheral
friends like oh yeah this guy oh yeah
yeah dude he's juicing and quite frankly
these were the people that were
in some cases it was like oh yeah maybe
if i was going to be getting on the [ __ ]
too you know what i'm saying like if you
were like maybe you weren't as jacked or
maybe you didn't like working out as
much as i did or maybe you didn't you
know you just were didn't have the
genetics to walk around at 210 220
right
and if you don't have that maybe you're
like bro yeah you know
and you're hanging around with a bunch
of guys that are jacked
so so occasionally you said you knew a
team guy the team guy
who got busted for steroids and got
kicked out okay there you go yep there
you go and i worked he worked with me he
told me the whole story he went down to
and it was weird they didn't do it
through a test though and this is how i
sort of found out i guess it's not like
i was looking for the answer or nothing
like that but this is how i found out
that yeah steroids are no go you know
teams at least because he went down to
mexico to get him that's where he would
always get him and then
this this is the story he told me where
he'd go there
inject him in mexico
and then um
he felt bad about throwing away all the
needles and stuff so he'd keep like the
needles and the trash and stuff like in
his like bag or in his pockets or
whatever the conscientious law breaker
and then so he'd have like they used
like needles or whatever and then he'd
so when he came back they caught they
caught him they were like oh you came
here for sarah this was like long time
ago like 90 something they being the law
enforcement or something yeah the border
guys or whatever this actually this is
like maybe 2002 maybe this is one when i
knew him and stuff worked with him and
then
yeah he said that and i was like oh
the story was weird like
that's a weird way to get caught but
whatever and he got caught and then they
reported it and all this stuff and he
got kicked out yeah that's
i would occasionally know of like
marines that were doing it
occasionally man but it was not legal i
do know that like you if you got in
trouble for it you were getting kicked
out is it the same now though because
let's face it that was a different day
yes
it is the same now oh [ __ ] it is the
same now now do guys have more knowledge
maybe where they can like know how to
skirt the system or whatever yeah that
is possible
but
with me my friends
bro like and my friends were in good
freaking shape you know we were lifting
hard and whatever like trying to be
jacked and you know what else we're
young and
you know when you're 18 years old you're
basically on steroids anyways because
you have so much freaking testosterone
in your system so we're we're big so so
that was my
um that was my navy career i'm not doing
something that's gonna put my whole life
at risk it's not gonna happen yeah
so then i retire and now when i retire i
got life and kids and houses and
businesses and all this stuff going on i
actually
that's pretty much when i stopped
drinking when i retired from the teams
now also i don't have any of that
that type of friendship directly all the
time and i'm just like and plus i'm a
little bit older and i'm looking around
going okay what benefit am i getting out
of this and i'm it's just a totally
different scene so i i didn't like one i
didn't retire and go like i'm never
drinking again
i just
looked up in a month and i had like oh
you know i had a couple beers here and
then two months later i had a few beers
and a couple drinks at this place or met
a client we had some what whatever it
was but then after like probably another
year i just looked up and i was like oh
wait it's been another four months it's
been six months
and then all of a sudden i wasn't
drinking anymore and and so that was
that and i and still was just like i'm
not doing any other drugs either
um
so that's what happened and
that's that's how my life has gotten to
this point where i really i i haven't
done nothing have not done steroids i've
never done any drugs other than alcohol
and caffeine
right which caffeine
again it's like
i
i use that at certain times yeah i don't
just drink caffeine all the time
um but
back to this video it's uh
it's interesting
it's an interesting video and it's you
can see this guy his name is derek seems
like a good dude like i said uh i've
watched some of his uh his thing is
natty or not
hell yeah because natty means natural
yes sir and not means you're what do
they keep saying other words for like
enhanced enhancement and then they got
all then i called all these other
slaying words for uh
it's pretty funny um
and what's your experience with the
sauce with the gear yeah with the
steroids yeah okay so
so yeah okay so which by the way i i
actually mentioned this to you too
it had to be a little bit of a bummer
that this guy does this whole video
about steroids that you're in the video
he didn't mention you once bro i was
like this is going to hurt echo's going
to be crushed whatever man
whatever they mentioned in the comments
okay you made the comments you read the
comments i think maybe you're up next
for 90 or not
echo charles
so i don't know you tell me if i've ever
taken steroids because it's one of those
weird things so okay so when i was 22
i'm 44 i'm about to be 44 by the way
right now
i was 22 years old i was working as a
valet i remember and i was lifting and i
was big at this point
like right now i was 2 40. okay at that
time yep
now we were lifting you know my boy
squatty lewis aka scotty lewis uh kona
police department i forget his position
but man shout out yeah uh he
it was me him and this other guy in the
books we'd lift and we were lifting
heart that was like bro you're about to
rat out squatty lewis for doing juice no
no no no no he's that these are just my
lifting parts oh okay i'm saying you can
confirm with him dude
after the video i called him up i was
like bro all right my numbers do i
remember this correctly he was like bro
he squatted more than me a little bit
and then squatty squatting all day um he
uh so anyway so we'd lift a lot and
um
so
there were other guys there were like a
number of guys who would who do
steroids not that would lift with us but
and they were big and they were strong
and i remember i got up to 240 and you
know in hawaii everyone's kind of bigger
just in general so i remember thinking
if i could get up to like
260 to 35
that would be a solid like 260 is big
yeah he's a big human bro i have the
picture of me 240 and the thing is i
don't look that big yeah most i ever got
to was 250. yeah i was a team two the
most i weighed in was 247. i was at team
two we were trying to get our platoon
weight average over 200 pounds and
everyone was just squatting oh yeah
but you know what even that we weren't
juicing yeah we weren't juicing yeah no
we're just lifting and eating and i
finally got to 250 did a four mile run
and i about died and i was like all
right
yeah i was not my frame is not meant for
250. yeah and mine wasn't either
okay so you're at 240 you're lifting
heavy yeah you know you kind of cap out
and um and you know when you kind of
when you get that kind of game because
when i stop playing football it's like
185
to 190. so you put on 60 50 pounds this
is over like about a year yeah but
that's a lot there's no one that's
complaining about 50 pounds of gains oh
yeah all natural all like for real all i
mean you know you get your k i remember
there's a supplement called beta gin you
know that i remember taking
um because my friend recommended it
whatever oh well if we're gonna bring up
i remember when uh when creatine came
out yeah i was on the crease
yeah i think it did too i was on the
creatine yep trying to get checked yeah
fully but here's the thing like okay so
the workout program that i was on is a
very effective workout program it's
still like i still do it today even just
for maintenance
but it is it is hard bro you know what i
just want to interject this thing when
guys are in seal training right now
they're not allowed to take
um
they're not allowed to take supplements
no [ __ ] because i guess along the way
someone you know popped possibly they're
like well i was taking this supplement
over here and so they just like okay
guess what
yeah yeah yeah dirty batch that whole
thing
so so when you say like are is it less
stringent
that to me indicates hell no
all right you know yeah yeah right they
don't even do supplements yeah can't
even prt freaking take mulk for crying
out loud you need to make a waiver for
that all right long long story short i
was like hey yeah some other guys that i
knew and respected like they were kind
of doing it yeah this is this is in 19 i
don't know 99 or something like that and
i remember
thinking yeah if they're doing it you
know like sure i'll you know so i kind
of hit them up or whatever and um and so
they got me if i'm remembering the name
correctly of it because there's a bunch
of different kind of steroids apparently
i did not know this
and it was like sus just sussed and
something
and it was like
these little vials and then you got to
get like needles and they're like hey
get the big needle this neat you know
the big needle that's the good one and i
was like when i was 12 long sir
when i was young i got a traumatic
experience with a bunch of blood tests
because they had to do a bunch of
surgeries on my hand for some stuff so
they blood test me a lot and they missed
iv a lot and so this is when i was 12 so
i did not like needles at this point
so i'm like all right i guess that's
what we're doing so cool so
um so my friend
he would he stuck me with the first one
boom puts it in or whatever and i'm like
okay cool like it's worth it no problem
if someone else does it you know like
okay so i'm like cool i think i don't
brad i didn't do research and this kind
of stuff i just i just seen the other
guys doing it and how strong and big and
and i was like of course it works or
whatever so
boom he sticks me with one and i'm like
cool to me the next day i'm gonna be
lifting way more than it was yesterday
like 100 so i go in there and i'm like
well i'm not even stronger it's like the
next day so i'm like all right
cool
so it was just one shot and then one two
three days and then the next week comes
around i'm not stronger at all so i'm
like kind of disappointed but then i'm
like oh maybe it takes a little while to
kick in whatever right so the next week
i go again i had another shot boom
so i go i'm working out my because i
know the workout is very regimented so
i'm like and each workout you kind of
it's like you're going for a pr every
single day it's it's for a certain
amount of reps and stuff like that
that's just the nature of the workout so
i remember freaking not even exceeding
my old pr like all this stuff like i
wasn't getting stronger at all and i was
like super and i'm freaking sticking
getting stuck with like needles and
doing steroids at this point
so i'm like oh freak all right so the
third week comes around
and i get uh he does one more and i'm
like cool and i go and still nothing in
fact one day i had a bad day i got a
weekday and i was like
this bruh these are not working but i'm
like whatever maybe i just got to do
more mega maybe i got to buy some more
maybe it takes um takes longer than i
thought then so my friend the next week
my friend is out of town he went like
somewhere
and i'm like uh
i don't want to tell anyone i'm going to
tell anyone dude can you do this can you
stick this in my butt or whatever
and so i'm like i gotta do it i gotta do
it so like
so i'm sitting in my room like it's
gonna be a bad edit right there
so i'm thinking that so this was shot
number four i'm on right i think the
number was 250 susta something 250
that's what this compound was
so i'm like
in my room like trying to do i can't do
it i can't bring myself to do it i need
someone to do it but i'm like no i'm
going to sat you know like i can lift
i'm strong i was strong already and so i
think i'm like tough or whatever and why
is this needle defeating me so i'm like
no i'm gonna do it and i
couldn't do it
it took me like one hour to just give up
and be like i can't i can't do it to
myself and my friend was out of town for
like three weeks it was like for the you
know for a long time
and so i just put it away
and then you know you kind of reflect
like what am i i don't really get what
i'm doing right now when i kind of
reflect and then so i still had like
three four or five more shots like left
in the in the little packages or
whatever
those are probably still hidden in the
mattress
in hawaii somewhere or somebody found
them or whatever but yeah never did did
those three shots
no gains in fact had a [ __ ] bad day
that's that's what really made me sad
like i'm like bro
i can see if i maintain and it didn't
kick into later but i had a bad day i
remember like thinking are these making
me weaker or something that's probably
because they didn't rest or didn't eat
or whatever they could but
no gains no benefit no nothing no side
effects no nothing i'm expecting to get
right raging you know because i was like
cruz i was pretty cruise mellow of a
person so i'm thinking oh maybe i'll
i'll be more angry and that'll be cool
you know like more and more more like
conf
what do you call when you confront
people more yeah confrontational you
know that'll help my little personality
or whatever
nothing nothing like no effects at all
like if if if i found out later that
those that batch was like
fake or not real i'd be oh that makes
sense to me because it didn't affect so
anyway that was it that was my whole
steroid experience um
but technically
echo have you ever taken steroids
yeah that's it that is 100 of my steroid
experience so i had a similar assessment
so i was on my on i was on deployment
and there was like guys in another
platoon
and they went on a trip somewhere
and
again like the reason i i didn't bring
this up when i talked about my close
friends like these guys were in a
different platoon i knew them they were
good guys and everything but like a
couple of them when they went on this
trip they juiced right
and they
and they came back and they're like the
rumors like hey these guys are freaking
doing steroids and i was like oh sh you
know i'm thinking the same thing you are
like these guys are gonna freaking just
get jerked yeah hell yeah but it didn't
work they weren't i was kind of like uh
really that that's like
so to me now i talked about the risk
earlier of getting caught now i'm gonna
risk getting caught
and it's over nothing
so that was another thing and then and
then there was a guy that was in the
regular navy and he was a freaking good
duty he was from i want to say he's from
america in samoa samoa
super cool guy we used to hang out and
he was jacked
and he was telling me he was like no man
like you should do a little bit
he was like saying you should do because
that's what he was like look man i just
do a little bit and it you know gets me
from
from you know 205 to 225. but to me
that's a lot yeah that is a lot but what
he was saying now i just do it you know
and that keeps me like i'm ripped and
but he was trying to convince me he was
like one of the early of just like just
do a
a small dose and that what he was saying
with a small dose but again i was just
like yeah dude
like i'm already to
15.
i need to squat more before i risk my
whole career yeah that's a big deal to
gain 10 that's freaking crazy to me so
yeah
so that was that um
but it in
all i'll say this to back in the um back
when when i did that i was already 240
and the numbers which i don't know if
you're gonna go into the video that
derek was referencing but and we went
into some numbers
and i was already doing those numbers
like that's when i was reached my peak
and then i was like okay let me take
something
found it in myself and be like yeah let
me take something to get more you know
so i did it whatever and since then
literally that was i'm 22 years old at
the time so since then
yeah just going that's all i did was
work valet and lift
so
since then bro i
got back when i moved to the mainland i
cut all the way door even before i moved
i cut all the way back down in fact i
remember being under 200 pounds here on
purpose really just to be more cut up
and just that was the look
so so uh
i'm talking about what you just said the
video right so there's the i forget what
the name of it i think the name of the
video is how much can jocko lift
which is guinea and it's skinny knees is
kind of like what i call that video
which is how this video by derek starts
off
and it has this little
clip
and just to give a little context around
this clip the whole way that thing
started
was me
talking about squatting yes the reason i
came in to work
talking about squatting because i was on
a on this on the squat train here well
here's before you even let that this is
important to know because derek does
gets this wrong in the video he refers
to it as the podcast like we were
talking about this on the podcast this
was not the podcast it wasn't literally
this was the point before the podcast
before we start the podcast we're just
talking trash yeah and if you watch that
whole video in the beginning yeah you're
like saying it's weird i don't even feel
like um putting on headphones today
that's how we start the video like this
is not the pocket this is before we're
doing and then we're talking about this
book and i'm drinking coffee i'm getting
things ready and all this stuff is that
is this one where you say like do i look
small is that the video nope
isn't there another video or there was
another time where i was talking to you
about like do you even squat or maybe
it's the same video the same video yeah
okay yeah because okay the reason i said
squat train and this is something i've
talked about before
i go in i go on different paths of
working out right like
for a while i'll just be like trying to
do
certain types of pull-ups or certain
numbers of pull-ups then i'm trying to
you know
do muscle ups then i'm trying to do a
heavy deadlift and i'm trying to squat
then i'm trying to sprint like i'll go
through these little phases just to keep
myself entertained different challenges
and also let's face it you get to a
certain point you kind of reach your
genetic capability or you you get close
to your genetic capability potential
that's what we call it potential and
then you're like it's going to put you
you know okay you get to you get to a
dead lift of
you know
4.95 and you're dead lifting 4.95 and
you want to get to 500. all of a sudden
you got to okay cool i'm not running
i need to just eat i need to gain
30 pounds like you're going to do some
things that are going to compromise
other aspects of your life yes your
jujitsu game your cardio game you're
running so
i have you know i go on these different
little uh uh trains these different
cycles of working out
and at that point clearly
i was just like in a mode where i was
trying to just get get get my squad on
so i was front squat back squat overhead
squat and i was talking that kind of
[ __ ] to you yes
and that's another funny thing is uh the
dynamic of you and me talking
there's a dynamic there right and i'm
trying to you know poke fun at you
make you feel insecure have fun with the
whole situation that's why the whole
video starts off with you saying like do
i look skinny and i without missing a
beat
like without missing a beat i'm just
like yeah are you trying to cut weight
right now without missing a beat yeah
like this is clearly just me
like you i can't tell if you've gained
or lost 10 pounds you know what i mean
but in my mind i'm like oh i got a
little insecurity over here i'm going to
pounce on that thing and that's the same
thing why when you're like 405
for 10
and i'm like that's good i mean it's the
same thing i'm kind of like you know
talking a little bit of [ __ ] making you
feel like oh damn
just providing some uncomfort for you it
was for 12 by the way was it for 12
yeah i confirmed it the other day
so
and again you mentioned this to me the
in the video i'm like yeah i'm a little
below there
and then derek on the video what's he
talking 375
and and then later in the video oh it
was for 10 on the video yeah yeah later
in the video i'm like that would really
hurt me right because i started thinking
about it because the conversation went a
little bit for me just talking [ __ ] and
to you into like a serious conversation
i'm like hey 375 for 10 would hurt me
right um
that being said i went and checked i was
like like going through some of my
records and i found because i do
10 reps for me is not something i would
normally do i'd do 20 reps
and i i was looking at some of my old
numbers and um
305 for 20. it was like something
something that i have done
385 for 20 and there's a that's a that's
a heavy freaking squad oh sorry 285
would i say 385 yeah no i didn't do that
and here's the thing this is a good
point too that you i think it's
important to realize it's subtle but
it's a big deal where
we were not and this is why i mentioned
this wasn't part of the podcast if this
was part of the podcast you better get
your numbers right yeah yeah but we're
talking [ __ ] just talking [ __ ] literally
like whether that got recorded or didn't
get recorded there is no difference
given the importance of the of the
information that we're going back and
forth just like literally when i said
when i'm like doing this and i'm like do
i look smaller and you're like yeah
are you couldn't wait wait like all this
stuff you're totally lying it's like
this is an unofficial off the record
conversation 100
so more than that a [ __ ] talking [ __ ] if
you were like hey jonko i want to
improve my squad what should i do i
wouldn't be like bro you need to you
know here oh you if you can't do 405 for
10 you're weak i wouldn't say i'd be
like well where are you at right now
right hey if you're getting this that's
freaking legit blah blah blah yeah so
it's a [ __ ] talking um
evolution anyways
but um i also say in that and he plays
this part
where i'm like i'm not strong
right
i say that i'm not strong
and then we talk about crossfit i'm like
talking about what the crossfitters can
do and
yeah so
uh
there's
[Music]
yeah so i'm not strong just to make that
point yeah i'm not super strong and even
you you'll be like i think you're strong
somebody made fun of that absolutely for
that
and you know why you think i'm strong
because you do jujitsu with me yeah and
i have technique in jiu-jitsu and i also
have
medium twitch muscles
i have medium twitch muscles so i can
hold
a lot of pressure for a long time okay
that makes sense not not explosive would
you say i'm explosive i would not say
explosive would you say i'm strong yes
sir yes that's it because i have
me and i remember i don't quote me on
this but the the theory or the discovery
of medium twitch muscles came out in
like the 90s
and
before that i would be a guy oddly
enough
i wouldn't win a long distance race
and i also wouldn't win a sprint
in my platoon
but if you put a 40 pound or a 60-pound
rucksack on me i would win or i would be
much closer to the front right why is
that medium twitch not super strong
not super endurance somewhere in the
middle
which is which means
i don't
really have the genetic capability
to be
snatching double body weight or whatever
like that's just it's very hard for me
to do that
um
so
so there you have it um there's some
funny
he reads
the dude derek reads uh a bunch of the
little quotes from inside there's a
reddit thread on this as well
hundred grams of milk 100 milligrams of
accountability
efficacious dose of discipline scoop of
getting after it ownership deployed
hgh for that huge head
and he says all kinds of
alpha as [ __ ] composure bro
so there's that um
so then he talks about the fact that i
work out three times a day
and then puts the own spin on it of
working out hardcore three times a day
which is a lot different than
me saying ah i work out i lift
i
run or surf and i do jiu jitsu and i do
that every day
that's
that's that's a that's an accurate thing
this isn't like hey i'm blasting legs
and squats in the morning
and then i'm doing freaking deadlifts at
noon and then i'm doing power cleans in
the evening and i'm doing all those for
max reps or
psycho med cons i'm not doing that yeah
so that's misleading and if that's
somebody that took me saying hey you
know i guess it's wrong for me to say i
work out three times a day what would be
good is like i exercise three times a
day right or something like that
um
so i feel like i miss i might have
misled uh derek on that one but it's
also the title you know that's the title
of this
reddit thread that he's talking about
um it says five hours of sleep a night
and
i
look i don't need to sleep a lot
that is
that is a fact um it's not even a good
fact it's just the reality of the
situation
the the other day
like if i go to bed early i wake up
early
you know it's not like i go to bed and
if i go to bed at
nine i wake up at
4 30 or i go to bed at 8 and i wake up
at 4 30. i don't my body doesn't need
that much sleep
um you know there's all kinds of little
funny stories from when i was in the
teams about me not sleeping
i know sleep is good for you i
i usually sleep more than five hours a
night i usually go to bed around
10
and i wake up at 4 30. so what is that
that's six and a half hours of sleep bro
so again do i sometimes go to bed at 11
yes i do yes i do i do i sometimes i
have a hard time falling asleep
so i don't sleep a lot
i've never slept a lot
uh two out of my four kids don't need a
lot of sleep genetically my wife
won't get out of bed until like there's
an emergency
because she's genetically different
right um so that's a genetic thing this
isn't this isn't a chemically induced
thing
um
but that's rare though and a lot of
people don't know that it's called fast
sleepers there's like this it's kind of
an anomaly or whatever where yeah you
just essentially you go through your
cycles of sleep just quicker yeah and
it's from what i understand yep and
yeah so so the sleep thing again if
you're taking that as an indication of
like oh he must be on the sauce
like
that's probably why he got that feeling
hey wolf this guy doesn't sleep much so
there's already a couple things that are
not accurate and again i can understand
totally how these conclusions can be
made if you kind of look surface oh
works out three times a day oh that
means he's doing deadlifts squats and
freaking power cleans
no i'm not doing that and if i did that
i would be wrecked right i mean i would
be direct just like a normal human um
and what's the other thing so there's
that oh yeah and then there's the
numbers
if i'm on that path
these are realistic numbers you know
yeah and it's it
i think he
took the numbers that we were talking
about which were
really what they were were like
estimated like predictions almost like a
they weren't hard in fast numbers like
even when you were like when i said if
you can do four wheels for 10 that's
good good that's literally what i said
and here's the thing and i was
explaining to carrie too when we were
talking about that it might have been
squatty lewis tail italians if we're
both wondering if you went deep you
wouldn't back up witnesses
coming to the stand i had to
the thing was on record at this point
you know so i'm like shoot let me
confirm you know um so
i'm thinking back to when i was 22 years
old
squatting
hardcore i think we're doing two or
three sessions a week of squats one high
rep one medium one low rep and it was
like and it was a hardcore workout
i was 240 at the time so i'm thinking
let me base on when i was really into
the numbers on squat let me base it on
that right because if you remember in
the video i say what do you weigh what
do you walk around there you're waiting
and you said 2 30. so i think i'm
thinking okay 2 30. 2 31 this morning
okay there you go um not considering
these three things which i did consider
in later on in the video if you watch it
where first off you're older than 22
years old
two you go all the way down yeah i was
going parallel squat which was an issue
that we're laughing at or whatever which
is also something that you now have
adjusted your mindset towards yes
because going in the hole
as we used to call it back in the day
which is below parallel
and that's another thing you just remind
me uh derek
in the video says like hey if you're
just walking around and just bang out
405 like it's nothing at 45 years old
that's that's an indicator and
i i can't do that
now if i was like hey you know what oh
it's
it's squat season right which squat
season for me is in the is in the kind
of spring time right
because in the summer i'm getting ready
to go hunting
yeah yeah in the mountains right at
least that's been the last few years so
that means i'm running i'm rocking and
then that carries into uh well this
particular year i've been doing these um
step ups with the 40 pound five pound
plate
i'm getting ready to do that chad 1000
uh which just extended that type of
workout a little bit into november
and then all of a sudden we're like
getting ready for the winter time in the
mountains which means front squats and
uh plyometrics and stuff sure and then
in the springtime it's like oh
you know it's squat season so
i it's misleading again i'm sorry if i
misle led uh derek to think hey joko's
just gonna walk up cold to a squat rack
and just put on 405 and just knock it
out of the park you know 10 12 reps
whatever and well and it i think and i
think this is important where when you
watch that video
and you really watch it and say okay
what are we saying right here when i
said
um and my standard was was kind of off
which i realized later in the video the
where if i say if you can do 405 um for
10 that's good good right at 2 30
because i'm making a reference to a 22
year old me yeah at 240.
um then after and then you're like
i think i'm there if not about there
right so okay so when i could when you
said that i think that's what people
latched on to
but when you said that you're like that
was just like estimate it was obvious
you had never done that you would never
like
that was a projection given what you
know you have done and then you made an
estimation and then you're like no about
there so no i probably couldn't get it
but maybe like under there if i had a
good day and squat during squat season i
maybe could get it that's that's how
what i got from then i said later i said
that would freaking hurt exactly right
the more you think the more i thought
about it same with me the same to me i
was like in i was like 405 then i was
like wait a second i was 22 years old
yeah i wasn't going all the way down and
then i just put it on the record 405 for
10 is savage all the way down yeah
you're if you're going ask the grass
four or five for ten is savage is savage
exactly right and then so then right
after i was like well if you can do
three wheels
for ten that's good that's good yeah and
then you were like well there's a big
difference and there is a big difference
and i was like yeah i get it i was like
but you're going all the way down and
i'm considering all these things that
i'm that come up in my mind like that
it's like bro that's a bad comparison
what i said and then you started
thinking even more about it and you're
like you're like
10 would hurt me 10 like kind of you
concluded no i can't get the 10. like
maybe it seemed like i could when i
thought about it at first but after a
while it's like no that would hurt me
like i couldn't get the 10.
um
and then you're like oh i'm not even
that strong or whatever yeah then you
went through that but um put it this way
there's a difference between really how
we said it
and what was going on there there's a
difference between that and then you
saying you know what yes i could get the
405 for 10
or actually not the 405 right under the
405 i could get that for 10 officially
like we were saying it on a podcast
there's way there it's way different
yeah and
and if there was no difference then you
could be like oh well jacob can or can't
let's say hijack who can't do that oh he
just lied on his podcast that's not true
yeah that's literally not true it was a
whole different thing you know it's kind
of like hey like if you ask me how quick
i could do a mile right now and i was
like oh
i've been wrong on my own
years before time you know like didn't
know and then i was like oh let me
estimate
given what i ran it be last time i ran
and then after you think about it all
this stuff and then then let's say the
next day around the mile and i freaking
couldn't get it at all oh you lied you
know kind of a thing
i didn't lie that's for that was the
conclusion i made my flimsy conclusion
not to say your conclusion was flimsy
but i'm saying it was based on other
factors rather than the actual number
and one more factor that was based on is
me just trying to make you feel weak by
being like yeah that's not bad yeah and
then you're like
like right away when i was like oh i did
um or whatever i did and then you're
like how deep like first thing and even
when we were talking about 40 time
you're like what kind of time are you
like you were yeah i was on a roll
uh so we get through with those three
sort of misleading things and again when
i say misleading i'm saying
i'm misleading
it's misleading if you do a surface
study of me and you see it works out
three times a day gets five hours of
sleep tonight and can freaking lift 405
for 10.
squat
ass the grass all those things which
derek
you know heard
and correctly heard them that's what
that's what was being said and or that's
what he saw
and he was like all those things
together this dude's that's one of the
things that made him lean towards and
again to his credit the whole time he
every time he'd say like um yeah then
he'd kind of back off a little bit as
well be
wrong uh there's a bunch of other
comments in here that were interesting
uh probably natty now but no doubt he
was cycling when he was active duty
totally wrong uh spec ops love gear
meaning the guys in special operations
all juice or love juice no not true and
this is from a quote former infantry guy
that knew lots of rangers on the stuff
i haven't worked with rangers enough to
do that assessment but
from my perspective if you're willing to
put your military career at risk
there's not a lot of guys that are
willing to do that
and this guy says hell it was unusual
to have guys not on the sauce when i was
in cav scout for five years again
maybe these are guys that were going on
deployment and there wasn't really
strict and there was more people doing
juice i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say um
i don't know i don't know i know that
when i worked with the army
these were not people that were on juice
like
and i'm and i'm more talking about
conventional army forces these are not
guys that are on juice so
yeah i
some of that too is like you're in the
military and you see you see a freaking
jacked guy that's in the seal teams
guess what the guy in the seal teams is
doing
for his job
working lifting
eating correctly getting better food
um
another guy says same [ __ ] as everyone
else gets they were saying that this guy
was saying that like people in special
operations get even better steroids this
is how just off the rails this is uh
then this guy says same [ __ ] as everyone
else gets we aren't allowed to use gear
whatsoever people do it and everyone
knows it i mean i didn't didn't know it
could it be that because i was end up
becoming an officer that people like hid
it from me and i didn't know it i guess
you i guess it could be that way but
i'll tell you man when you're working
out with guys and training with them and
all of a sudden they just like get super
strong i would be suspect
i was very rarely suspect yeah
um
he talks about what i looked like over
the years
and here his conclusion is like dude the
guy has just always been kind of
a bigger dude
which is true i weighed 174 when i
showed up to buds i was 19 years old
i weighed
200 at the end of my oh i gained 15
pounds or whatever 11 pounds i graduated
bloods at 185
got my first platoon i got up we were
lifting our goal was to be bigger
i got up to
200 my first platoon i got up to like
215
my second platoon really
i got up to like 220 my third platoon
and you know these are like ages i'm
getting bit i'm just getting bigger and
stronger it's like you know you went
from 180 to 240. right these are prime
years to get jacked when i was competing
in jiu jitsu now we're talking like 96
97 98 i would always be around 220 and
i'd cut down to 213 so i could do the
weight category and then the absolute so
that was my weight back then but again
these are not
you know um crazy numbers
i was at seal team two got up to 250 how
squatting eating dead lifting more
eating
um and that's so he kind of says that he
kind of says that
um that well you know he's i forget the
terms he uses there's no you know time
where he's just
you know goes from being
128 pounds to 220 pounds there's no time
like that and they're it's true
it was a steady slow progression as i
got older it got bigger until i reached
about 2 25 230 which is where i am right
now
uh he couldn't find me talking about trt
and then he found one tweet where the
tweet had been deleted but i had said
haven't tried it somebody probably asked
me have you ever done trt
do you remember that tweet
i don't really remember it but i saw it
he put a clip on there and it's
definitely me and
i'm sure somebody said hey have you ever
done trt i was like yeah i've never
tried it because there was a tweet below
it that said something like oh i'd hate
to see jock one more you know
testosterone something like that so he
figured it out and yes and then he said
that was the only quote horse's mouth
of me saying anything about trt which is
not that weird because i don't talk
about it because i have no experience
with it i don't it's not something that
comes up
um
and and look i'm not even against it i'm
50 years old if i get to a certain point
where i'm like yeah you know i feel like
[ __ ]
but my doctor says to me hey jocko this
is going to make you perform better and
do better maybe i'd be like that sounds
like a good idea what i don't like about
it is i know that when you do that stuff
you're on it for the rest of your life
which to me is bad i don't want to be
relying on anything i don't want i would
rather be able to make my own
testosterone at a lower level
than go on fake to go on
other testosterone
and then
have to be on it for the rest of my life
like i don't like that idea
to me that's sort of a dependency which
i don't like
so
but but again when i'm 60
and all of a sudden i'm really weak or
whatever i have issues
i'm you know i i'll be like hey guys i'm
going on trt right now
i want to be stronger
which would be
fine
uh
so that's why maybe he hasn't found a
lot about me talking about it and again
i got friends
that do trt that talk about trt
i've just never done it
if i did i wouldn't be ashamed of it i'd
be like hey this is the situation i was
in and this is what i did
you know and when you start going down
this path it's like um
i mean if i'm trying to like stay young
maybe i should start by dying my hair
black which my hair is great i don't
give a [ __ ] probably good idea yeah i
don't give a [ __ ]
it doesn't matter to me no you're here
to win yeah
um
then he finds a a picture of me or
there's a picture of me on like the
reddit thing it's me and ted tim kennedy
and we're sitting there talking or
whatever and we just got done with a
workout
and there was
there was some funny comments
it says looking solid dude another guy
says alpha head bro [ __ ] sick cranium
which is you know funny and somebody
says look at his jaw line he never
needed juice he's a natural granola he's
got gorilla he's got shrek genetics
somebody says big not abnormally ripped
which is totally true i remember that
that magazine article came out about me
in success magazine yeah and they said i
was a
ripped
225 pounds of muscle and i went
and did a fact check publicly about that
article and said i'm not a rip 225 i'm a
well marbled 230 which is the truth
um
[Music]
somebody said just by his head i don't
know what's up with my head
somebody said just by his head you could
tell he's out there as [ __ ]
uh
but see some people are pretty like
these people are saying hey this if you
look at the they had a picture of me
when i'm probably 25 and a picture of me
now
and people are like yeah look at him
when he's 25 he's he's his head his
jawline cause you know when people do
steroids their jaw gets bigger their
cranium gets or their uh
their brow like what is this their
forehead or their their eyebrow bone or
whatever that is gets like bigger and
more prominent
this is just the way i look and i've
looked that way since i was you know in
my 20s in my early 20s
um
this guy says not necessarily cranked
looking
oh no this is what this is what uh derek
says not necessarily he's like oh he's
not necessarily cranked looking but a
very [ __ ] built dude a solid human
who would be very tough to move if that
makes any [ __ ] sense yes it does he
looks mean he looks tough as altitude
ortiz's superior older brother which is
i've i've trained with tito i'm not
superior to tito tito is
a jacked dude like what did a tito fight
at did you do
205.
i was going to say either one indeed
five or two or five tito fought at 205.
tito was a freaking monster tito's 6-2
and huge
he's a monster bro
and so yeah i'm just saying i'm not a
genetically uh or physically superior
tito ortiz and he tito ortiz also had
like the explosive type muscle right i
have the freaking slow
slow the medium twitch the medium touch
but all these things i i thought that
might that section was kind of leaning
towards like hey this is just a kind of
a big dude that that literally eats
steak
drinks milk
and lifts weights that's what i that's
what i've been doing for a freaking long
time right yeah this i'm not a guy that
like goes on hey i'm going to work out
for i'm not that guy i'm not a guy that
goes hey i'm going to work out for a
little while and then i'm going to you
know
get into painting right no i've been
lifting
you know whether it's calisthenics
whether it's plyometrics whether it's
squatting whether it's cleans whether
it's doing pull-ups like that's all
in the that's all in the freaking in the
element you know
um
then he goes in this weird tangent in a
jujitsu
uh you got it got a thing with me and
going against jeff monson and jeff
monson
he calls him all kinds of
calls them all kinds of funny names uh
and and jeff monson is an incredible
grappler he's a monstrous guy
who's
pop positive for steroids before
i'm not sure i shouldn't say that
i'm quite
i'm quite confident that he has utilized
um steroids in his life but not yeah so
so he sees me going against him and
what's interesting about that video
there's a video of me versus jeff monson
unfortunately the video is 2 minutes and
30 seconds long
that was a triple overtime match so i
forget what the first it was like a
seven minutes
and then two minute two minute two
minute overtime and it got edited down
we had a pretty good scrap and jeff
monster's a better grapple than me and
he's stronger than me and he beat me
like that's what happened he mentioned
how like um he's a he goes oh he's a ufc
champion he goes no no he's he's not a
ufc champion he's just an 80 i don't
think he said a justin abccc or he goes
he's adcc champ kind of like oh he's
only an abc's that's more significant by
the way than us ufc exactly right if
you're a dcc abu dhabi abu dhabi combat
club
champion that means in grappling no
punching in what you guys were doing
he's the best guy in the world straight
up yeah and
if you're the champion which he was and
i will say the two minutes and 30
seconds of that video i look horrible
like i see me now and i'm like god i
sucked and that's what we always the
goal is always to be bet to be able to
beat you six months ago that's always
the goal
and that's a 15 year old video and i
look and i go god what kind of shot was
that oh my god you look like crap why
don't you do this that's just what it
feels like when you watch old videos of
yourself so
um i was in that tournament by the way
that's my first tournament i ever
checked yep yeah i lost to jeff monson
um
but what's interesting is
he's
he makes this argument that like if
you're gonna compete if you're competing
in this stuff which i was
why would you not do steroids like
everyone's and he makes this whole thing
about how jiu-jitsu there's no testing
for steroids and i don't know if they do
now but back then there sure as hell
wasn't any testing for steroids
um but he also says my physique's not
that much different
and i probably weighed in at that
tournament at 220 because i was probably
only did heavyweight at that tournament
i probably weighed 220
and
he said there's no indication of the
deployment of anabolics
and then he but then he can't like he
doesn't want to believe that he says
well it'll lead you to believe that
maybe he's just using it for recovery
so hard uh and then he says or he's
never used it
so again i think he's a little bit
conflicted um
but he says look if if there's if
there's so much juice in the jiu jitsu
world why wouldn't you do it
and here's one thing i wasn't really a
competitor yeah you know i would if
there was a tournament well when i was
going to college
um from like 2000 2003 we competed all
the time and and actually before that
when i was at fabio santos man dean and
i competed all the time we were going to
every tournament we could go to we were
competing all the time but
you know by the time 2000 but once the
war started actually is when i started
competing less and less because i wanted
to be like ready to go to war
but for him it didn't make
any sense
to be competing at that level which i
was competing at a very high level you
know i did the adcc trials um
for him it and he used the words he's
like i'm highly skeptical that that i
wouldn't that jogger wouldn't try it you
know
which again this whole time i'm active
duty in the military by the way i have a
job i have a job that i love i have guys
that i'm supposed to be leading and
taking care of and if i get
[ __ ] canned from the teams because i
wanted to be a little bit bigger
and by the way i was already pretty big
i wasn't like
158 like god i'm i i wish i had more
presence
i was freaking 220 225
um
also with jiu jitsu i think it it's
it's fair to know this where
just because you compete in jiu-jitsu
doesn't mean you're you're a competitor
pursuing champion
level yeah like even if you come you can
compete on especially back then even i
mean now it's really like
there are competitors and then there's
everybody else no matter if you're a
black belt high level whatever you know
so a guy like in your position you have
a job your active duty military um love
jiu jitsu loved it loved
even the number one thing on my priority
list no not even by long shots no
[ __ ] teams bro if you if you wrote
out your goals even even if you narrowed
it down to your jiu jitsu goals it
probably wouldn't be to be world
champion it's usually not that now there
are there's a large group of guys that
that is their goal then you might start
seeing okay this guy's on steroids this
cousin sir because he's pursuing a very
specific goal and he has to go hard as
hard as he possibly can and he's going
against guys that are who are testing
exactly right he's going against guys in
the same boat exactly exactly right but
the fact is a lot of us even high super
high level guys they're not in that boat
until you shift your goal to be
champion
champion
it's just a different type of jiu jitsu
person i was
a hobbyist in jiu jitsu yeah that was my
hobby i was very passionate about my
hobby and believe me you're not going
i'm not going to the competition saying
i don't care if i want to lose no i'm
freaking trying to win
but i'm not missing
a block of training with my platoon
because i'm going to go and train more
that wasn't happening yeah exactly it
wasn't even close
if you're not in the in the jiu jitsu
world it it might you might not know the
nuance you know you might not know the
difference
between even when you say hobbyist that
kind of from the outside might sound
like oh you just do it on the weekends
and whatever like you can be a hardcore
hobbyist
every day it's physically possible to
get it done oh heck yeah and
um and then you have guys who are just
competitors where it's like i have
jiu-jitsu and i'm gonna do as good as i
can possibly do in jiu-jitsu hopefully
become champion and and everything else
is secondary that's like no matter how
good or junk they are that's like that's
the two pursuits you know
yeah um
so he goes through the jujitsu thing and
again that to him makes him lean towards
i must have at least tried it so i could
compete with these guys but like you
just said i'm not trying to win the
world championship i'm trying to win but
i'm not that's not the number one
priority of my life and then he goes on
this
thing about uh some guy named dave
blizzarian dan bill blizzard okay
so this guy apparently went to buds at
some point and he this guy who
went to buds
said he did steroids and said a bunch of
people a lot of quote a lot of people
did it which again this is weird
this is a this guy
just went to buds
and he got
didn't make it so you don't even know
what kind of person this is i don't know
why this he's even brought into the fold
here other than
you know he's like oh this guy dave
bulzy and said he did it's like
okay well this guy didn't wasn't a seal
made it didn't make it through training
he did say
it seems that
he uh
you you could get kicked out this guy
this guy that went to buds mentioned
that oh you would get kicked out if you
got caught so right there
what kind of freaking you know that's
like like right there that's all you
need to know anybody that knows me
like oh you want to be in the seal teams
and there's a risk you get kicked out
for doing steroids by the way
when i was going through seal training
i was passing the evolutions
you know i wasn't like hey
i got a i got a freaking
27 20 on the run i want to get that down
to 26.40 and i'm willing to risk getting
kicked out of the navy to shave 20
seconds off my run time or 40 seconds
you're never gonna do that yeah i would
never do that it's a stupid thing to do
so
again and then and then the same guy
says that if said that a third of people
were juicing which again
that's not possible i could understand
if more people than i think are on
steroids i can understand that
but to say one third of people in
special operations are on steroids that
is not that is that cannot be true
because i would have
known a lot of them
yeah i spent my entire adult life in
special operations
yeah so it seems like you would know
more so than dan bilzerian and
you you don't know um bilzerian that
much but he's kind of known for just his
whole
thing being just real wishy-washy
as they say as far as his stories and
claims go check uh
derek says that when i wasn't training
he was on this ring about how when i was
in training it was less scrutinized
like steroids were less scrutinized and
i was like i
and he starts bringing up arnold
schwarzenegger i was like bro like i
could go through i didn't go through
seal trading in the freaking 70s when
when steroids weren't even you know
we're just on the open market so i don't
know what that point was and i guess he
tied some connection i guess there was
some big steroid olympic thing that got
a lot of scrutiny brought on it but
again i didn't really i don't really
know much about that uh i will i if
anyone in my actual seal training class
did stories i'd be totally shocked no i
never even heard anyone talk about it uh
at all
so
then he goes on this thing
about how
my
life is about stress
resiliency and grit through adversity
and a lack of sleep and he's even
talking about lack of food fasting
sometimes
and then he says whilst and i like that
he used this word he says whilst
maintaining a high level of performance
that's what sort of my my life is like
and he says that
it's like um
that that
i would benefit highly
from exogenous androgens
which yeah so he gives this thing about
how you know i'm all about being strong
but going through adversity and having
stress resilience and and he says
would this guy would benefit highly from
exogenous androgens
obviously pretty telling in my opinion
that's what he said so he's like this
guy like is all about the stress and
getting through this stuff that's pretty
telling in my opinion that's what he
says so again it's not a
it's not a it's not a
it's one of those things that makes him
lean a little bit more in that direction
and then he goes on this thing about how
i was going against sauce fiends back in
their primes
oh talking about munson and not using
[ __ ]
when even the gracies were using [ __ ]
and he talks about the fact that hoist
gracie tested positive for anabolic
which i i think always tested positive
for ana for steroids
when he was
like in the ufc or something i don't
know but i no i think it was i think it
was later i think it was one of these
sort of older horse fights right right
yeah um and so he so then derek says
it's hard to imagine this guy's not
dabbled before
to go into to go into matches with
literal houses and not thought maybe i
should get a bit of help
it's obviously crossed his mind a couple
times i would imagine
and again oddly enough
getting kicked out of the seal teams all
i needed to hear was
you know that one story when i was
younger about
hey they take all the batches they test
them and if you pop if they if they find
any one of those batch
test positive they test them all
individually you'll get kicked out cool
done
so this wasn't this this wasn't this
temptation that was on the back of my
you know on my shoulder all the time you
should get strong a little bit stronger
and by the way i wasn't getting out
muscled on the jiu jitsu mats
monson wasn't
tossing me around yeah
no at no time did i feel
like a little bit more strength would
make me better i was
to be contented with also too with the
steroids in jiu jitsu a lot of times
sure the guys are a little bit bigger a
little bit stronger but like how you
kind of alluded to that's less of a
factor like the fact the real factor
with steroid guy versus no steroids guy
is the guy can just turn up the pace and
keep it going and wear out the guy way
quicker and where the guy's just less
effective because there's way less
energy
more so than and well he wasn't doing
that either like he didn't like turn up
the pace where you couldn't keep up you
know that wasn't going on either it was
it was just simply a jiu jitsu match
that he ended up winning not not by a
lot like you know in the overtime or
whatever but it was it was clearly not a
match between steroids versus not
steroids it wasn't that he didn't beat
me because
of strength
he beat now if i had been 10 times or
three times stronger than him sure
but he beat me because he's a better
grappler than me he
wrestled he's he's the adcc champion of
the world
that's why i got b
um
and let's see
he he goes
he goes back to the he goes back to the
the skinny knees video sure and starts
kind of breaking that down a little bit
he says that i'm 5 11 230 which is what
we kind of discuss on that and then he
says this interesting thing he says
he says that i jocko was built like this
the the whole time the entirety of his
historical data represents when he looks
at me and sees pictures of me when i'm
younger
i always kind of look this way he says
there's no massive aberration in body
composition always been a husky mild
house of a dude
which is i would say a factually
accurate statement okay uh goes goes we
already talked about the 405 for 10. he
kind of does a little bit of a deeper
dive than that
and we kind of already just talked
through that that's a
[ __ ] talking combined with an assessment
yeah and
an estimation
and that was that um
well
he also says
he says i can't imagine this is legit
when he says i haven't tried it i would
probably call [ __ ] on it
so many times he would have been it
benefited from it so much more than 99
of other humans it's hard to believe you
would just grit through it with your
[ __ ] natural crashed hormones which
ultimately will be with the amount of
stress you are undergoing with the
amount of sheer environmental factors
that he has imposed upon himself
so he's saying that
just the life i've lived
has been
stressful
and hard on my mental status hard on my
hormones and my hormones are all project
up so why would why would i
try and grit through this with my own
what does he call it
[ __ ] natural crashed hormones
and
uh
what is what is this one
yeah so so that's what he's made that's
what it makes him think
and
he thinks there's just no way that it
makes sense
for me to not do that
um
he
then he finds a video of me
shooting an arrow
he says
he's like oh yeah and here's here's a
video of him with no shirt on and
it's he's shooting an arrow with his
alpha [ __ ] head
[Laughter]
so that was kind of fun funny
um some he reads through some more
comments that i'm a genetic outlier
that it's trt one person says sauced out
of his mind
another guy says he's 50 definitely some
exoneticist exit are you saying that
exogenous exogenous compounds in play
someone else says steroids take jocko
someone says this jackal wouldn't risk
his career that's an accurate statement
that's that's the most
that that probably is the root
for me
of never doing steroids or any other
drugs at least for the 20 years that i
was in the in the seal teams
i'm not risking that and then i get out
and who what am i doing am i
getting beat up on the jiu jitsu mat no
am i
weak
no am i having a hard time getting out
of bed no i feel
freaking great so why am i all of a
sudden thinking
you know you and i you and i were
training hardcore
were you ever were you ever thinking
yourself well you know i just kind of
powered out of this if jocko gets you
know what i mean i didn't feel oh i
better get stronger
so i can do better against echo um
so that's kind of
kind of what he what he says so i think
this is my um
he says he says something like his
that odds are
um
he derek
ends up saying that he thinks i'm
you know used steroids in the past and
he only uses the word dabbles but and is
on trt right now i think he says good
and i think the reason why he i think he
was leaning towards i think throughout
the video he kept saying things like
well you know he's always been this big
and he's not
ripped he's saying all these things that
kind of make him think no yeah but then
i think that
that the
people that he interacts with all the
time like who's his
friends and his group
it didn't even make sense to him that i
would compete in jiu jitsu and not right
do steroids or at least consider them
that didn't even make sense to him so
for him to look at me and look at the
training that i do
and
the fact that i'm 50 years old and think
yeah this guy's got to be on trt or
whatever or is likely on trt i think
that's just the group of people that he
talks to that he's around
that's what his experience has been
and it's just it's just a separate world
than mine
and that's what he thought and the fact
of the matter is i ain't yeah i'm not
i've never i've never done any drugs
yeah and you know what i'm on monk
i'm on joint warfare i'm on steak
um i mean elk
has been delivered to the house the elk
is going down
um
yeah
so you had your uh like the record so
and because this is a significant part
too about the claim of the numbers of
squatting and whatever so consider this
so now you know right because you went
back to your actual records you did 305
for 20. yep right so i guess the
question is and and i'm not saying for
you to answer i'm saying for us to kind
of consider as far as claims go uh if
you can do if someone anyone anybody no
matter how big or small if they can do
three or five full rep squats for 20 do
you think they could do 405 for 10.
you know there's a little charge to it
you know there's little charts that they
make for this kind of thing yeah and i
don't know what the how that would work
out because those aren't that accurate
though because you need a certain type
of muscle performance
i don't know
i don't know yeah so that's right of
course not neither do i no we don't but
if you estimate you know like especially
back when i used to do i never really
got into consistent 20 reps for any
exercise but 405 is heavy
i would say 375 is in the game you think
i think i think that's uh
yeah yep but even that's not i wouldn't
bet money on it yeah i wouldn't bet a
lot of money on it right you know yeah
but if you're let's say if me and you
were like you know what we're gonna do
this we're not gonna film maybe we are
we will film i don't know whatever and
we're gonna be like hey we're gonna do
today we're gonna do our pr for 10. what
are you going to go for
you got one shot what are you going to
go for
and if you think
i'm putting on 405 because i think i can
get you know like you're not going to
put on 450 if you don't think you can
get it if you think i can
get it
and you say i think i can get that and
yeah that's within the claim of not
being like
bs or whatever yeah it's an estimation
not crazy yeah it's not crazy it's not
crazy right now all right well that's it
um
speaking of mulk speaking of joint
warfare speaking of krill oil speaking
of discipline
jockofield.com
we talked a lot about jiu jitsu you
should train jiu jitsu yes sir not about
strength strength is not uh
it's not out of the equation
yeah it's in the equation it's in the
equation
but it's not the total equation
technique
is a more powerful part of the equation
you made a good point though about like
the circles that you kind of hang with
the people that you hang around the
community you're in or whatever where
um
like if you're used to seeing people on
steroids or whatever it starts to become
more and more like it feels more likely
that of course they are of course they
are you can just take one or two little
things even if it's kind of out of
context it's like okay i'm not gonna be
surprised if that person is but it's the
same on the other side too where and i
was like this when i was young like
especially with um with other drugs like
cocaine right i never tried cocaine ever
probably when i was living in hawaii i
never even seen cocaine before
i came to the mainland and still
really i haven't really seen that much
cocaine one time i saw a guy and i
worked at the nightclub by the way but
it just in my brain i hadn't been around
it so i'm thinking of course no one's
here doing cocaine that's crazy that's
the stuff you see on the movies
one time i saw a guy get out of his car
and he had like cocaine on his nose
still and i was like baffled like oh my
gosh this is such a big deal
meanwhile my friend's like oh
yeah everyone like
what's the big deal kind of a thing and
i'm like okay and it kind of dawns on
you if you're not used to it
or if you're really used to it
yeah it's just a foregone conclusion
like okay yeah okay it's almost
surprising if you don't see it kind of a
thing yeah so that makes it that totally
makes sense yeah and even now that you
bring this up even in the seal teams
like i mentioned it was a book i had a
sister platoon one time that was some of
the guys in there that had a click of
guys in there that were into that that
did juice
and so
if one of my friends would have been
like bro i'm gonna go on the sauce i'd
be i'd be very surprised by that yeah
but if one of those guys was going on
the sauce i'd think oh well that's their
crew
so and it's the same thing with trt
right there's a lot of people that go
onto trt a lot of them and i know a lot
of them yeah and and so to think oh well
if you're a if that guy's already
assuming that a bunch of the people that
i hang around with are on trt well why
wouldn't i be on trt too
and well the fact of the matter is
i'm not
and it goes for lifting weights like the
numbers that guys put up like okay so in
hawaii people are just bigger just nor
in this part of the culture by the way
but
i've seen guys you know bench five
wheels and and a lot of them too like
four 405 was like if you do 405 you're
like yeah okay you can they can do four
or five it's good but
everyone's seen that before and in the
seal teams there's not too many guys
that number one bench press very much
not branch press very often and
certainly anyone that's bench pressing
five plates in the seal teams is a
freaking super strong dude everyone
knows that dude yeah everyone goes oh
dude he can bench freaking 500.
everybody knows that yeah it's so rare
so
yeah same thing if someone says oh yeah
that guy can badge 500. and
it's it's talking about a guy in a
platoon that would be a lot harder for
me to believe unless i knew the guy
right and what if you've never seen and
think about who i was hanging with from
the year 1995 all the way up until 2001
when i left jack football football
players exactly right these big samoans
and stuff and whatever i'm thinking back
to the numbers my friend jeff ulrich
who's like he played for the 49ers he
was like he's one of my friends and he
was a big strong guy
and
i remember like later on after he moved
away or whatever and after i lived here
for a while and i remember thinking back
wait jeff ran a 4-5 he was 255 pounds
and 6-1 that's huge that's the answers
again around a four four five forty
which is four four five yes sir a four
five forty four how much did he weigh
255 this is a mutant yeah any six one
here's the thing when i remember jeff
yeah he was big and strong and an animal
or whatever but not that when i'm
thinking about that now i'm thinking
that's an animal but when you're in that
community when guys are like six three
three oh five walling around and when
they hit you just [ __ ] die for three
days you know and that's the norm yeah
and guys go in the weight room and like
they don't even warm up and they put two
wheels on there and they're just like
awkwardly doing it like they've never
benched before but they can do it
because they're just so natural and
that's kind of the norm
compare that if you've never seen anyone
bench 405 before you see four plates on
that thing you're like oh my gosh i
can't believe that guy did that like
yeah gave me a better explanation to how
that's possible you know i had a i had a
cb chief that was with me in ramadi and
he was jerked monster guy his name was
biggie
that makes sense right completely but
yeah he was he was throwing up 315 on
the bench
honestly it looked like if i put if i
had the bar yeah like that's what he
looked like jacking 315 for his warm-up
yeah so and and because again in the
seal teams guys aren't doing that kind
of weight you guys can't
and everybody
that rumor sport that word spread bro
biggie was freaking benching 405 for
reps
everyone's shocked derek was inquiring
kind of how much you bench do you
remember your best bench
350 was like my best bench ever and my
bench my bench is weak that was always
the weakest thing that i have yeah your
squad is your gym
what's your best exercise dead squat i
don't know man
i benched uh a 405 i started i talked to
squatty lewis he said that he remembers
me doing more than four or five
i feel like i did more than four or five
i remember specifically doing 405 for
the first time
did 3 15 12 times
my best
um 285 on the incline 285 15 times yeah
yeah for me 350 was
like a goal
yeah it was hey this is what i'm working
towards but i was i was never good at
bench i was always had stronger pull
muscles right
dead lift or whatever i was always
seemed stronger in that area yeah but my
shoulder press was always my best one
check
all right dude
that's it that's it for the dmz uh
appreciate y'all hanging out
here in the dmz with the demilitarized
zone
appreciate it y'all check it out
jogglefield.com originusa.com
just go to jaco.com and get after it
we'll talk to y'all later
out